hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to they breathe a game about
frogs which is pretty much all i know
about the thing because there wasn't a
lot of information beforehand
all i know is that there's some
breathing going on there's frogs
involved
and it was two bucks so i'm willing to
throw away my lunch money so that you
guys can determine
whether or not this is a good game for
you
so let's give it a try well aren't i
adorable and slightly creepy
press space to swim faster one final
hint well this is some delightfully
dirty looking water but
oh look at me go it's got some physical
elasticity to it the movement is very
elegant
and the bubbles are very free-forming
and i'm did i mention that i am a frog
because even though i'm playing the game
currently now
oh my what the hell was that
i'm not sure if this was intended to be
like a horror game or something along
those lines
mildly disturbing why the hell is there
oh hi
uh hello um friends fellow frogs
stay the hell away from me what are you
doing
why do you crawl towards me like that
are you crying for help or am i supposed
to avoid you at all costs
because i have a feeling that the latter
might be the one that i need to
do why are you screaming god why are you
screaming you're intentionally creeping
me out
i'm gonna go down here excuse me pardon
me stop
following me so i'm assuming that there
was some sort of a flood
and that these frog type creatures which
are totally not used to the water
can't figure out what to do they just
seem to be in a bit of trouble
okay i'm gonna touch him because oh
well all right then they get a night
group to him i like things with a good
gloop
what the hell am i supposed to do i have
no idea they're just kind of weirding me
out
sky you get away from me i know i got
tasty frog legs but you back the hell
off
why is one of you are you turning
different shades of green
one of you seems to getting getting a
bit more what do i do with you
oh wait a minute oh am i supposed to
push you to the top
oh okay maybe
that one's definitely getting more red
where did i go
i am bright green that one is all god oh
god i thought he was bleeding for a
second there
what the hell just happened to him yeah
you stay away yeah yeah you don't like
that do you
somehow i'm not good for your health
what the hell you were green before
i don't know what i'm doing here excuse
me sir could you please back off there's
a weird bush over there
it's squiggling you're squealing weird
oh maybe oh i get it they're air bubbles
oh he's looking for an air bubble well i
gotta either keep him away
or lead him to it i think i pretty much
killed the other one
that oh oh god i need air bubbles don't
you dare take my air bubbles
ah now this is making much more sense i
am going to win
oh oh god
he just upped and died that's cool too i
didn't want to
become an environmental massacrist
because apparently i think
[Music]
i don't even want to know what the hell
that is
looks like some sort of moose frog it's
a froggy moose that kind of looks happy
in one direction and then the other
direction it looks like
100 nightmare ah
it stole my air you son of a [ __ ] get
away from me you're the weirdest thing
i've ever seen in any game
is it dead did i kill it is it dead i
really hope it's dead
how in the world did a flood cause a
bunch of mutations among the wildlife
here
it's more specifically the frogs the
frogs are the canary and the coal mine
for the
nature did something just explode
okay you're back hi friend how you doing
you seem to be running low on air you
you guys you guys have some fun
oh god damn nope so apparently every
time i get some wawa
or air air yeah that's right you fall
you leave him alone
you leave jerry alone what did he ever
do to you and he exploded
there's two of them now oh god i'm dead
i'm so dead
get away from me what are you doing to
me stop it fight each other thank you oh
i'm so dead what do i do oh god i can't
do oh god
i think i got aided
i don't know if this game is
intentionally terrifying
but i do not want to live in this world
please take him take jeremy jeremy will
take my place
please steal him away but don't turn him
into one of you
i'm gonna go utilize him
why am i down here why are you a crazy
frog moose
why does anything anything okay let me
try to get some actual good commentary
here because most of this has
been with me going what the hell has
been going on here
i don't want to go down how about i
don't how about i don't go down because
going down seems to be bad for my health
what are that there's something oozing
and pulsating
you know normally i like oozing and
pulsating but there was another explo
okay
okay i'm gonna go this way keep you guys
away from the error
i'm gonna go over to my froggy buddies
there's rhythm and blues
and the other guy's name is bob okay no
you don't no i don't i'm gonna dodge it
this time
you don't know what's gonna happen to
you cause i got the air bubbles i got
the 100 air bubble supply here
i'm cornering the air bubble market you
stay the hell away from me god damn it
he got another air bubble
god damn it he's consuming another
douche uh rhythm of blues are you bob
bob rhythm and blues r b is a cookie
that is not the hug of life that is a
hug of air death
i'm gonna go over to the pulsating thing
because what could go wrong
what could go wrong get away from me
you're a weirdo
you should not breathe i know the game
name is they breathe but
i don't even think you qualify as an it
her she or he
it be yeah that's right yeah you get out
of here
going down into the deeper depths that's
cool too
why is this game terrifying me to the
core this game was only two dollars but
i feel like this experience is scarring
me for life
okay there's another explosion more
pulsating goober gabbas
you know part of me is very very happy
that this forest got flooded because to
be honest i think there were some
problems
what did this turn into a bullet hell
game get away from me
stop calling mr moose man are you the
byproduct of a mutated moose man
are you the precursor to a moose man you
like the caveman a moose
moose gay man oh you're green where
where are you green
what the hell was down there that
mutated so weirdly i get it
you're gonna irradiate my air supply so
i need to be very
i don't know how in the world i'm gonna
be able to get past you because you seem
to have cornered the market
oh god that hurt ah what do i do what do
i do what do i do
why why why why why why i don't want any
of your poison
you are a son of a [ __ ] you get out of
here give me god damn it i almost had
that
i need air i need that please
swim faster space that was alright i
forgot about that that's one tactic that
i'm probably gonna need
because if there are explosives out
there there's gonna be mutation
happening
and i don't much care for it i don't
much care for it
oh can't catch me i'm going for that
sorry jeremy
oh god that hurt ah give me give me give
me you i'm too bright for you
oh that hurt i need that no god damn it
you're a son of a [ __ ] oh
i had it on lockdown if you wouldn't
have cornered me like that yeah you hug
me but you better be warm cause i hugged
back real good
and that guy was not very happy with the
oh i'm actually alive
i thought i was dead
let me out let me out let me out let me
out thank you i killed him
somehow i'm still alive i don't know
what is going on here
i'm actually not entirely sure what is
happening but i think i made it out
although i'm starting to suspect my
green skin tone might actually be
radiation and there's bigger pulsating
goober gabbers down
here what is with the pulsating guber
gabbers
what was going wrong in this forest was
a very stoned witch out here
one that was experimenting with some
spells on the floor okay you're weird
no thank you i would rather not sir i'd
rather not
you're swimming very quickly but i'm
quicker oh god you're fast you're fast
i gotta make it you're gonna get me i'm
the fastest frog in the side of the
pesos
pickles no not today not today
frando you ain't gonna get a piece of me
you want a piece of the mean green
you're gonna have to um okay looks like
you got me pretty good here ah
that's what i thought yeah that's right
get out of here so when i get captured
by the
pulsating gubergamus the precursor to
the moose gooby gabba
and not the same with the pulse oh maybe
that is the same as the pulsating goober
gap is down there
i'm gonna have to i'm just gonna i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna i work
good unit oh he got me i'm gonna guide
you towards one of these there we go i'm
free
so what about that so does he actually
need to get me
because there doesn't seem to be any
actual way to get out of him huh
come here where's that air it's over
there
that's right rip apart you don't oh
you're not dead
well this is getting strange what kind
of fever dream did this game idea come
out of
actually i don't mean to criticize this
is actually really cool
and in equal parts cool and disturbing
mostly disturbing
very much a lot disturbing okay how am i
gonna serve okay you sons of [ __ ]
you all fight each other cause i don't
even wanna be bothered yeah you come
here yeah you get me oh instantly kicked
out
so i'm having a feeling that these oh
that's not good
oh that is not good i'm gonna go
here you get me oh no
oh no oh god oh no this is actually bad
what i meant to do is get up excuse me
pardon me uh pardon me i need to get
through here
because there seem to be some air bubble
uh things
that i okay i got my old friend hey how
are you doing again
got to see you got to see how's the wife
and kids uh dead
good god good for you
how the hell am i gonna kill all these
[ __ ] yeah
i'm guessing that they actually don't
want to touch air cause they seem to get
more pulsating and disturbing
so maybe i just need to swim around them
as they actually collect the air
now i'll force them into it boink so
what kind of brave frog am i
that i decided that i would take it upon
myself
to dive down and destroy all the
pulsating gooby gabbas
no i need that i need to get out please
no this is not
oh yeah you think this is advent okay
epic combo there but i'm still dying
still dying still almost dead good god
god need that thank you
come here pulsating blow okay that hurt
no thank you i have almost finished this
i will finish this fight crap okay one
more for that guy
come here you and i can do uh no i
cannot
come here i really got nothing else to
say about this game it's almost
reached the level of normalcy that i'm
not used to i need air
i need air very badly thank you i think
i claimed the big bubble that comes out
of it no
no you do not oh no you do not okay you
did you did you actually did
i said you shouldn't but then you did
yay did i win
did i win guys i think i may have won
if only you guys could see how proud i
am of me
i'm so glad that i did that because i am
my own best friend
nobody else so
yeah going into a hole that is the
scariest
okay explosion that is literally the
scariest thing uh
hello my old friends don't know how to
get rid of you
cause i don't know if you actually don't
want air and i don't know how that
little frog got out here
he's not one that can actually hurt me
so oh that was normal
oh yeah i was out real normal oh
yeah all right we're just gonna pretend
like that but it's gonna
okay okay
sorry buddy this is the way the world
works
oh you let him go okay that er never
mind you can have him
i don't know what to do he just went
down and exploded him
don't please don't that's that's right
you don't like the air
you guys don't like air for some stupid
reason they breathe it's actually i
breathe
and you don't breathe nothing but poopy
i don't know
i've really run out of clever things to
say not that i've ever had anything
clever to say before
i'm going into a deep pit in the ocean
where some strange nightmare creatures
have come out to haunt my dreams that's
cool
great okay you're dead thank you
thank you for that don't know if i'm
doing good at the game
oh good i think i like this
i think i found the bottom i don't want
to go in the hole
i'd really rather not if that's okay
i'll go down
okay good for me going in the hole god
that is the creepiest thing
underwater holes in the water ground
is not something i am a fan of i'm
actually very
unhappy with any of that hello how did
you get down here
okay i saw i don't need to get touched
by that
i don't know i don't need to get touched
by that okay good yeah you
yeah i saved your life aren't you happy
happy that i'm here for you
touch it god damn it touch it you stupid
frog you got
touched what is happening no don't be
nope
oh come on that's not advantageous to my
situation
oh i needed that you're a douche
god damn it these sons of [ __ ] are
all up getting him up in my grill
my frog grill no not even a frozen girl
is that something that you're supposed
to get or not do you get
air or do you not get air i don't know
where's the air coming from anyway
get out of there you freaky freaky man
actually at this point i actually am
kind of used to it i mean there's only
so much of the
absurdity that you can handle before it
becomes normal and then your life just
becomes kind of
any kind of level of absurd there's
another explosion
it's commonplace now hello friend how
you doing
how's the weather down here water warm
enough for you go
to here yeah you get that
it's weird because i can actually take
shelter in these big ones
oh no i'm totally safe not gonna be
god damn it no no no no why am i hurt
no this is bad i can't die now i've been
so alive
oh okay hi that okay this is not going
okay i want that air
thank you thank you very much go down
here now i take it that you're just
going to swap heads for a little bit and
i'm just going to
grab into this one and steered it okay
you kicked me out
is that how it is no no no no no no no
no no no god damn it come on just let me
live for
two seconds come on yeah touch it yeah
you touched it does it feel good
feel good man
good only one more for him he's gonna
get it
get it get it get it get it no ah don't
give me your frog
because then you shrink back down you
freaking [ __ ]
ah touch that don't swap frogs
top fallback frogs this is weird
one frog perp weird jellyfish body
i want to go down i want to progress if
you could stop swapping frogs for two
seconds
very appreciative that was probably not
a good idea considering i am close to
death
oh god did it die finally now i can just
focus on killing you you
[ __ ] oh no you're gonna blow
you're gonna beat a blow so hard thank
you thank you for dying in a convenient
manner
but i have a feeling that's probably how
they reproduce because those little
glowy bits
probably attach to the bottom and become
more of those stinking
thingies hello jeremy
how's it going you doing good you see
these weird things don't know how you
got down here
but you know what frankly hey jeremy are
you serious right now
you took my spot in the guy fine
whatever
just leave it alone go grab jeremy
you have jeremy alone thank you jeremy
you took my air i was gonna kill him
god damn it damn it jeremy
stop it god what have i told you about
frog swapping
this is not oh come on no you let him go
you let him go you bag of ass okay never
mind
yeah that that yeah that's that that's
exactly what i wanted
thank you thank you in fact no you
better not saw god damn it that okay
good
ow no no no
ow no no no stop it
thank you okay so we're just gonna kind
of back up a few steps and kind of god
damn it oh god damn it i went for full
okay that was my hair thank you so much
for being a giant
i give it give it to me thank you
thank you so much for being a giant
douche i wanted to steer it back a few
seconds
so that we can focus on what's important
here the
story the story would be good can we
focus on that
thank you i would like to know why this
is happening
let's get some bets going who thinks
it's aliens uh
virus fungus those are your options
that's
all that it could be oh and irradiated
dumping into rivers it's a very
uh ecological state
oh
[Music]
oh god so the air that i've been
breathing this entire time has been your
fart bubbles
is that what you're trying to tell me
here
good good
so happy for me i knew it too those
things go back down then they grow more
i know that's how this works i
understand it because i'm very
intuitive and smart maybe not smart
maybe not so much intuitive either at
least i can
yell my way through a situation good
good good for me
i know what i've been doing i know i've
just been creating more
i know that's all i do my purpose in
life is to fuel your
machine of nightmares and terror in
shadows
so in a way you're welcome you know what
you're welcome you are very welcome
for all that i have done in service to
the crown of
things that you are thank you in fact
thank you and you're welcome and you're
welcome for
all that i've done
what do i do just kind of wondering
what i'm doing here wondering why
wondering for what reason
just going about my business
so i'm assuming that they breathe in
this equation was always these frogs
trapped down here
and maybe through some divine purpose i
thought that
me going down here was gonna be some way
that i could save them
because obviously i was just sitting on
a log frogging a log i'm sure there's
some
childhood fairy tale theme about all of
this god how many of you do i need to
blow up
oh i get it okay i was a [ __ ]
i was a [ __ ] that's what i was i was
dumb
i was exceptionally and incredibly dumb
thank you for that
thank you for calling me dumb i had no
idea that i actually needed to get one
of those things to actually touch
the doo dad there so that was my bad
that was my bad that was actually my bad
yay one down don't know what that did
for me
thank you excuse me pardon me sorry so
what do i do about you
what do i do about you what does one do
about some diabolical monster at the
bottom of a lake
of a lake hole in fact and you're dead
are you just dead or do i need to rob
you of all your frogs
so that you will be able to breathe no
more come down here
yeah get that frog oh yeah oh yeah you
got to swell up
you're going to blow up i'm going to b
to blow you so good
you don't even know how i'm gonna beat
the blow you don't even know
you get that other frog yeah
yeah you're so slow i'm gonna need some
air
please sir thank you thank you for that
air there's good air by the way
once again i gotta get your recipe when
all this nightmare ends
hopefully someday soon
don't know when are they dead yet are
they dead yet
are any of them dead what's with your
moose
you're calming you cow man not feeling
so good
cow people cow raucousness
i'll take that thank you and you're dead
god damn it i need some air
hey froggy bastard jimmy come here no
i'm gonna i'm gonna take this
you're gonna come over here i'm gonna
grab this last frog
boom oh my
was that a good thing i did did i do a
happy thing
did i win
oh my god it's me i'm flying
that was the end i am victorious i am
the winner i am the one who
knocks i did it my froggy self has
managed to accomplish the impossible
i have beaten the demon at the bottom of
the lake
and i have defeated everyone and saved
the entire world from this
extinction of flood and death
or maybe i just ruined a new species
that was just trying to live
i mean who needs frogs anyway maybe
they're just the bastards of the rivers
i collected many frogs as a child and
maybe i should just shut up now
but either way in all seriousness that
was a really cool game totally different
i love when a game is just totally
bonkers
nuts to the max so either way this game
is available for two bucks two bucks
it's like a short
uh 25 minute experience if you're not as
awful as i am
but um either way that was a lot of fun
so check it out hell
oh wait oh oh there may be something
here
ah i just made it good job froggy friend
and you even got jeremy to leave with
you
ooh there's a hidden gallery online so
as a reward for all of you
being able to watch this playthrough to
the end you can go to that website and
input the password i guess
and you can get to the hidden gallery so
thank you all so much for watching leave
a like if you enjoyed this video and
check out the game in the description
below
thanks again everyone and as always i
will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
i keep pressing that button i'm sorry